me di cuenta que respondí mal el
problema 94 del vídeo pasado porque se
me olvidó una hipótesis quedan ahí en el
problema entonces vamos a hacer la toma
2 vale entonces 94 problema 94 vamos a
ponerle tomados tomados ok dice en la
escuela jefferson school hay 300
estudiantes esto es lo que me faltó 300
estudiantes y estos estudiantes estudian
francés español o ambos entonces
estudian francés español o ambos a ambos
también nos dicen que 100 de estos no
estudian francés 100 no estudian francés
y la pregunta es cuántos estudian
francés y español entonces una vez más
vamos a hacer el diagrama el diagrama
que sería algo así ahí tenemos los que
hablan francés de este lado tenemos los
que hablan español lo voy a poner un
poco más a la izquierda ahí tenemos los
que hablan español entonces estoy aquí
es francés ya no quiero círculos esto de
aquí es francés esto de aquí es español
y vamos a ver qué nos dice dice que hay
100 que no hablan francés y justo los
que no hablan francés son estos de acá
verdad los que están de este lado
de este lado de acá estos de acá nos
dicen que son 100 y además lo que nos
piden es cuántos hay aquí entonces dejar
de poner lo mejor entre en color blanco
queremos ver cuántos estudiantes hay
aquí en la intersección que hablan tanto
francés como español y lo que tenemos de
información posible es en el inciso 1 en
el inciso 1 que de los 300 estudiantes
60 no estudian español 60 no estudian
español entonces eso querría decir que
este cacho de acá es de 60 estudiantes
este de aquí es de 60 vale pero sabemos
que en total son 300 estudiantes por lo
tanto tenemos que 60
60 más los que están en esta
intersección que le voy a poner francés
español más estos de acá más estos 100
es igual a 300 a 300 y entonces restando
bueno aquí tenemos que francés español
más 160 es igual a 300 simplemente dice
la suma de 100 con 60 y restando 160
los tenemos que los que hablan francés y
español es igual a 140 vale entonces
aquí hay
140 de modo que el 1 nos permite
responder y en el 2 en el 2 lo que nos
dicen es que hay 240 que estudian
español vale entonces en total aquí
tenemos 240 entonces si no supiéramos
cuánto es aquí y otra vez es francés
español pero entonces francés español
más bien dice que es igual a 240 y de
nuevo tenemos que francés español los
que hablan ambos es o los que estudian
ambos es igual a 140 sale entonces
cualquiera de las dos sirve para
responder y entonces la respuesta es d